bonjour bonjour ma été c'est le jour de
la marée aujourd'hui quel merveilleux
tableau vous avez préparé on a une belle
table et c'est pour faire quoi et bien
on va faire une soupe de poisson alors
la soupe de poissons du toit on en voit
dans tous les livres de cuisine bien sûr
et je ne connais pas de régions de
france côtière où on ne me dise pas nous
nous avons la vraie soupe de poulet très
bien manger à quelle est la vôtre
et ben voilà la mienne c'est très simple
elle génère sept ans et c'est comme ça
alors pour ça il nous faut faire tu
souffres passante du sauternes
oui il nous faut de l'oignon il nous
fait de l'oeil de l'échalote la
ciboulette des tomates de l'estragon des
preuves du laurier des parures de prêts
soit 100 de l'huile d'olive
il nous faut en grisé il nous faut
bonnes annotations veut en 2d n'est pas
obligé des crabes d'émuler un gros d'un
ragondin incongru oui et là c'est un
mulet en mêlée voilà je suis revenu bon
alors pour nous résumer les deux
liquides c'est plus simple et plus
important donnera besoin constant ces
deux sont d'ailleurs annoncés le sauter
mais les collines de livoye là alors
ensuite on pourrait revoir un petit peu
ces poissons alors les parures c'est
très facile tous les poissons ils
vendent des clients leur demande
quelquefois des filets donc on peut leur
demander avec la donne ça par exemple
c'est une parure de grisaille il aya une
parure de soleure sonne ça se trouve
très facilement chez les poissonniers
tourisme last une tête de mule elle est
superbe magnifique ça c'est une tête de
gourdins je crois c'est sa voix la terre
les cramer vert les craintes vous avez
dit qu'il était vivant mais qu'est ce
qui peut bien courir ils vous aiment pas
ils nous cachent un peu ce superbe but
l'est du bassin d'arcachon
voilà à côté de chez vous et le congre
je crois que vous avez dit c'est pas
très joli alors savoir deux jours les
maires la revoilà on peut pas l'utiliser
tout le congo c'est surtout un an
poisson qui sert épaissir la sauce
alors cette partie vers nous on s'en
sert pas parce que vos coups d'arrêt
on ne sert que de croire que kodak très
bien là bas vous allez nous montrer tout
ça et j'imagine que pour commencer vous
allez on va faire un goût nous y voilà
bien costaud et qu'allez vous mettre
dans votre combo lyon eh bien on va
mettre tous ses petits légumes c'est à
dire l'oignon l'échalote le terrain de
lauriers on va le mettre dans de l'huile
d'olive chaude
oui
aller retour et seulement oui juste pour
que c'est le temps de prendre le pouls
de nos leaders
là on va saler poivrer bien entendu
voilà peu pas trop quand même
oui parce qu'on a fait chaque instant la
bombe a fait au nom on fait aller retour
voilà que sa 5000e d'huile d'olive et
bien c'est bon et on m'avait l'arroser
avec une algue et vous la route y avait
quelque chose en terminant toujours de
liquide l'huile d'olive et c'est
l'essentiel est là dessus on a des
glaces la très peu un petit peu cette
fois à chaque fois voilà voilà
alors là on va le mettre dans une
cocotte pour ces choses mon dieu mon
dieu un siphon là dans une cocotte dont
nature ni sérieux ni salaire il faut
avéré du tout et aux envies la bienvenue
on est dedans oui et on recouvre et on
recouvre non je vais pas on va pas
couvrir tout de suite je vais rajouter
maintenant j'ai de suite autre chose
alors là je vais y mettre la ciboulette
ont un petit peu oui un petit peu de
ciboulette ou pas beaucoup on va
carrément le groupe est directement là
dessus parce que là ça bouge ça vous
savez vous voilà il y en a c'est est ce
que vous allez vraiment pédestre à gond
bien sûr estragon tout frais en donnant
la chance d'en avoir
oui alors là c'est pareil enlevé comme
ça laisse trois enfants anne-sophie oui
là et là je vais recouvrir oui c'est là
que je vais recouvrir ma cocotte
voilà ce qu'on appelle rationalité les
parlers par le vent alors qu'on va faire
chauffer comme à faire passer dans la
poêle pareil avec de l'huile d'olive
alors on va y mettre 4dans macabre que
l'église est apparu le sol avant la tête
de müller
saler poivrer un peu et pas trop rêver
des droits de distribution petit peu
pendant ce temps je vais me mettre ce le
reste dans ce qu'ils voulaient pas cette
façon c'est chaud ici qui sont très
chauds alors là je vais mettre mon
oignons ou j'ai piqué des clous de
girofle de là à mal vous en avez
mais les mêmes six mois après on va
mettre la poêle et la tomate
je vais couper grossièrement voilà parce
que je fasse en même temps qu'eux savent
accueillir le référé pour vous bien sûr
la chanson déjà pas mauvais alors qu'est
ce que ça va être âpre mais rien n'est
que le début
voilà les tomates savent à vocation
voulait tourner le rôle honorable henry
s'est déshonoré s'explique nous sommes
d'avis de saisies dans l'huile pour
prendre le pouls voilà où à l'avenir de
matoto tomates et je vais mettre mes
poissons qui sont passés de côté vous
leur donnez pas un qui peut avoir de
sauter il ya eu aussi triste urines et
bien sûr chaque fois quatre fois l'huile
d'olive et sauternes un petit filet la
résille yen et au dollar dans la marmite
animé tout l'huile de sauternes tout au
tout et tout et on recouvre et nous
allons voir la suite
on s'occupe des poissons nobles
maintenant c'est à dire on va mettre à
cuire
voilà restent à leur place a donc vous
avez pelées et coupées en deux trois
coups de couper en deux là c'est le
grondin voulu supprimer la queue non non
non on va leur mettre plus un morceau de
chacun oui on va garder la moitié oui et
vous nous expliquerez après pourquoi
bien rue voilà on est tous à revenir
amie de l'un et la salle tout entière en
à maintenir non parce que comme moi ça
contient maintenant moins la moitié de
la seule au delà voilà
saler poivrer bien entendu même
opération au havre est le temps que ça
dort un peu on va pouvoir continuer
d'écouter peut-être un peu oui
[Applaudissements]
après si je sois même chose rivard et
des biens qui lui il est très chaude
mais par les olives voilà outre-rhin
ajouté deux autres
saler poivrer des deux côtés parce que
moi ce sera un dp oui et rebelote
ça va alors le gros muet l'euro millions
est ce que c'est bien la peine de dire
qu'on l'a vidé et qu'on avait payé ce
qu'on aime tout le monde sait bien que
c'est quand même un recours c'est un peu
dur on va lui couper la queue aussi
évidemment ah oui avant de sortir la
presse à supprimer n'en a pas besoin
voilà ils doivent être bon on est dans
la coque est là bas non alors je vais
mettre ça un petit peu avoir un petit
peu de sauter de sauternes
voilà des glaces et on est peu parce
qu'évidemment que l'on donné à chaque
coup on ferait sous voilà un tout petit
heures règle a ses bières et or en avant
alors là il ya le congre remet lui la
ville un petit peu je recouvre tous
apprennent bien bien bien avoir coupé le
compère la wii a chauffé a passionné qui
peu après en mai tiens celui ci la
moitié aussi oui la lro congrès et le
nom vous mettez le grondin avant et
après et le groupe en tout seul parce
qu'il est gros il entremêle à dans la
poêle non voilées opération afin de ré
saler poivrer sur les dauphins et des
glaces les lis ça lui prendrait des deux
côtés un petit peu de notre peau terne
voilà c'est bon là et vous allez la
ville a versé la désaubaine allez y en
ait un net rebond
non non non au yen à rendre compte on
referme et toujours à petit feu d'huile
c'était un comble un concours de grande
taille des états monsieur autrefois chez
nous et pourtant m'a dit qu'il n'était
pas très grand celui là au nom et aux
plus grands et référant directement une
rêverie
mais là il va plus loin un joli mais
roland va l'envoyer là on dirait paquet
on a entendu un bruit mais là il y en a
moins fait un morceau non seulement
parce qu'après on va vous expliquer
pourquoi
appréciant le couple bâtiment soit en
s'amusant là là mais vous faire à ses
oreilles au lieu d'un petit coup de
chauffe oui j -mp en huile sel et poires
des deux côtés notre petit coup de sang
terne
et voilà un petit coup de sauternes et
de grosses annonces faites pas comme ça
non en fait je vous sais donc oui on y
va et versailles et alors là on bat bien
arrangé tous ces poissons
ça y est ça et on veut couvrir ça sent
la 2 1
évidemment une bonne chose qu'on a mis
oui et maintenant il va falloir
s'occuper des crabes des crabes
je les coupe 1 4 oui voilà
et je vais les mettre dans ma poil à
revenir aussi à l'olive aussi chaud
rires après saler poivrer
toujours pareil voilà
tout y est un petit peu il est retourné
sur les deux pas du tout pareil
voilà et on va les repas c'est ici aussi
un petit peu de sauternes
voilà vous avez vous un peu la manip
octobre
voilà c'est bon
avant la date et la mi plan ça n'est
qu'au mieux ça gâche rien et on couvre
et on attend 4
[Musique]
la soupe est terminée oui mais quel
travail à boeing a été récompensé ce
qu'on a pris tous les petits morceaux de
poisson on a tous les pyott et on
enlever les arêtes y en a des belles la
canaliser les petites minutes
c'est une longue patience et ensuite on
a tous partis aussi souvent là on a
pilonné et ça fait une soupe et il est
récompensé et puis en dix minutes avant
la fin de la cuisson
on avait mis les jolis morceaux qu'on
avait gardées les belles pack de crabes
qu'on va même au dernier pour les
retrouver ensuite dans la soute et voilà
si vous avez envie d'en faire autant il
faut beaucoup de patience
inviter tous vos amis pour tout
décrypter avec eux et ensuite vous allez
voir votre récompense parce qu'une soupe
comme ça c'est la fête c'est alors
essayé et à bientôt
à bientôt et bon appétit
[Musique]